beaucoup de souvenirs sur ce plateau et
soutenir de plaisir du cinéaste italien
luca guadagnino on connaît surtout à
mort et b que splash son remake de la
piscine son nouveau film qu'hormis
bayonnais y raconte l'éveil amoureux
d'un jeune homme de 17 ans auprès d'un
ami de ses parents pendant un été
italien
adapté par james ivory d'un roman
d'andré aciman il est nommé quatre fois
aux prochains oscars meilleur film
meilleur acteur pour le très jeune
franco américain timothée chalamet
meilleur scénario et meilleure chanson
originale pour soufiane stevens de quoi
en faire notre événement de la semaine
un oscar
ce serait le début de la consécration
pour ce cinéaste italien et prix de
beauté et la sensualité à va peut-être
ah ouais ça serait le début alors
effectivement son précédent film vigueur
ce plh qui est comme vous l'avez dit
était un remake plus ou moins habile de
la piscine avait déçu oui plutôt moins
que plus ils avaient déçu ce film parce
que trop plastique parce que trop creux
et alors là qu'on se rassure guadagnino
se rattrape tout à fait avec only by her
name qui est une gracieuse romance et
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus en temps ce
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus réel et
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus beau que
l'amour quand on décide quand on a 17
ans le cinéma de bois danino c'est un
cinéma très sensuelle très léché qui est
inspiré d'autres cinémas son cinéma en
miroir alors à la fois le cinéma
français la nouvelle vague à la fois le
cinéma américain les comédie de billy
wilder par exemple et bien entendu le
cinéma italien il ne cache pas son
admiration pour rossellini pour
bertolucci et aussi pour scola et tout
ça on le retrouve donc only by her name
mais véritablement et c'est à la fois la
grâce de l'italie du nord de l'italie à
la fois la poésie de l'été à la fois
voilà on a envie de vivre danse il fait
visiter mais oui je vous fait visiter
c'est absolument merveilleux je vous ai
rapporté deux séquences qui met blue
hills alors la première c'est une
séquence extérieur nuit
helio et oliver donc nos deux futurs
amants sont en soirée il ne s'est pas
encore rien passé entre eux mais le jeu
de séduction est manifeste
alors là vous avez remarqué et lyon est
en retrait au début il est observateur
et celui qui est au centre de l'action
et bien c'est oliver bien sûr la douce
enveloppe qu'on remarque c'est
cette imagerie pop des années 80 les
couleurs et c est là qu on a un léger
mouvement de recul de la caméra qui
entre dans la danse elio il est
définitivement dans l'action et les
presque sur ressorts vous allez le voir
et c'est lui qui fait le mouvement du
cadre qui est absolument sensuelle et
ravissent envoyé la photo qui est
absolument sublime
on est dans un jeu encore une fois très
enfantin et puis la deuxième extrait on
est extérieur intérieur jour un petit
aperçu de la maison du bonheur dans
lequel se passe
cette histoire est là la musique tient
une place absolument capital dans le
film y avait la musique pop dans le
premier extrait est là c'est de la
musique classique du bac
et qu'est ce qu'on va faire helio et
dérives a joué la carte de la
provocation musicale avec oliver et
entre eux il va y avoir ce petit côté
taquin amusé à la fois très impressionné
qu'est ce que fait elio il rejoue un
morceau qui la jouait dehors à la
guitare sauf qu'ils le jouent
différemment et qu'est ce qu'il fait il
change de registre il change les
variations il change de style et
finalement tout ça c'est un petit peu le
fond de leur histoire à tous les deux
qui y voit là et on a remarqué ces deux
corps une distance de sécurité entre les
deux ils sont tous les dr sun il ya une
attirance absolument folle mais il ya
quand même cette distance
qui est maintenu là vous voyez le talent
de shalla mais qui joue véritablement au
piano est absolument saisissant ce duo
de comédiens et est formidable et
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que cette scène
nous dit finalement et belliot nous dit
je joue selon mes propres règles le
personnage de l'hiver mais avait dit on
rejoue la exactement cette chanson comme
tu nous l'avait joué dehors mais non élu
on ne le fait pas il n'écoute pas voilà
tu là encore changer un petit peu et
c'est tout ça ce film c'est absolument
merveilleux c'est absolument vibrant moi
ça me transporte ce qui est marrant
c'est qu'il joue aussi un musicien d'un
type de greta garbo que lady bird
guillemette alors ce scénario pudique de
james ivory cette photographie dont vous
parliez du chef opérateur d'apichatpong
weerasethakul et de miguel gomes je
crois tout ça filmé par la sensualité de
luca cattaneo qu'est ce que ça donne
pour ça donne effectivement le plus beau
des romantisme parce qu'il n'y a rien de
plus romantique qu une sensualité
pudique qui se cherche qui se provoque
légèrement ivory c'est retour à howards
end et c'est donc là on a l'impression
que c'est le petit corse est de
l'angleterre victorienne mais plongé
dans le lac de côme avec des superbes
petit short jaune canari qui donne envie
et tout ça les deux lots dont on entend
les cigales ya de jus d'abricot pressé
maison dans le choc nerveux
comment comment quel que soit l'âge des
personnages leur sexe etc
il ya des parents compréhensifs cultiver
fin effectivement c'est une vie rêvée
marie c'est une sorte d'idéal moi je
suis alors sur le romantisme
moi ce qui me frappe c'est l'érotisme du
film parce qu'on parle de sensualité
mais appelons un chat un chat et ne
reste dans le film c'est vraiment un
signal du désir guen alignait donc voilà
dans la mollesse et s était une femme de
40 ans qui a une aventure torride avec
un cuistot dont leurs mecs de la piscine
c'est tout le monde à poil autour de la
piscine et on se souvient de nos années
rock et de nos coucheries exterran et là
c'est la naissance du désir chez un tout
jeune homme alors outre que le tout
jeune homme est absolument délicieux le
film est long et donc il prend le temps
et ça c'est absolument merveilleux parce
qu'on s'y coulant s'y sent bien
en vacances on est en italie en échec
ces gens dans une ville la sublime avec
des gens intelligent raffiné drôle
merveilleux on voudrait toucher la
pellicule enfin ou semenya regardé
l'émission science l étude américaine 1
mais moi je vous suis mis les oies non
c'est à dire comme en d'autres temps il
est moins lointain on aurait dit du bien
du fiptr la face aux assauts des
moulinages d'amour j'ai obligé d'être un
peu réservé excusez-nous d'être
enthousiaste scianna et je n'ai pas
hésité à la projection dire que le sim
guys accueil je suis d'accord avec marie
le film est très long la dernière
demi-heure est très très belle mais
avant je trouve que sa peine à démarrer
et est par exemple je trouve que le
personnage de cigarettes est mal écrit
elle joue très bien mais tout ça est
quand même un petit peu pâteux moi je
rejoins quand même l'époque du cinéma de
james ivory
alors lire je ne me souviens pas qu'à
l'époque james ivory on disait qu'il
fallait absolument que ça ramasse tous
les oscars et tout ça veut dire c'est de
ça dont on parle faire est ce que c'est
un bon fils oui est ce que c'est le
meilleur film de l'année
je ne pense pas et après quand vous êtes
dans vos rêves de revivo 17 ans oui il
ya quand même de temps en temps ça petit
peuple à tous et donc simon valois
parler d'amour polymorphe
il ya quelque chose autour de la
fluidité amoureuse et sexuelle qui est
très belle dans le film moi ce qui m'a
touché plus que cette enveloppe alors
oui on vivrait dedans mais il faut pas
non plus laisser croire aux gens que
c'est un truc incroyablement
programmatique ce n'est pas un film doux
du tout c'est moi j'ai été très souvent
surpris par les agissements et par la
psychologie des personnages et il
m'étonne toujours il ya toujours un
moment
chaque personnage finit par me
surprendre dans le film et je trouve ça
extrêmement beau est ce qu on fait autre
chose j'ai envie de dire qu'un buback
mountain en italie c'est vraiment un
programme qui est charme aussi par son
humanité
et puis pour répondre à philippe sur les
oscars on ne peut pas détaché ce film du
contexte de sa production dans une dans
un moment un peu plus rita arrive ce
film c'est ce que vous disiez mariche
heureux s'ils demanderaient légumes vous
saurez pourquoi
quel jeu aux caresses qui va gagner moi
j'y crois pas beaucoup aux syndicats je
dirais le scénario peut-être mais
scénario adapté meilleur scénario adapté
deschamps cela serait formidable qu'un
jeune comédien comme lui qui est une
vraie révélation là dans le film qui lie
à partir de piques à daniel day lewis
il va y avoir du sang camby bayonnais
mme luca guadagnino alesi de notre part